hey it's something I love about you and
which is what was my dog my dog Henry
laying his laying down back there he's
my old man but but so one thing I love
about you and we have similar or it's a
similarity between us is I love an oily
throat when I'm in the studio singing
and I heard that like when I'm in the
studio I have to have this is the
weirdest thing ever I order two
hashbrowns from McDonald's and I just
loop it up and that's my recipe and and
I heard that you do you have like is it
bacon well did you say that Aretha
Franklin rest in peace I love her so
much she used to eat potato chips potato
chips and then I've heard chicken
because baby face to me that we first
worked together and I was like I can't
believe I'm talking to baby face and
he's talking about Aretha Franklin her
process is my life but ya know I I heard
that it's the same that she gets soul
food like in there because the grease is
it up and it kind of leaves it up sorry
I didn't mean bacon wrapped around it
we like spicy mustard and I just be so
happy mouth is watering subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going